economía en directo américa de francia
24 luis méndez zúrich bienvenido
nuevamente vamos a iniciar hablando de
reino unido porque ese país ofreció los
datos de desempleo hoy martes así es
raúl de acuerdo con la oficina de
estadísticas nacionales la tasa de
desempleo en el trimestre comprendido
hasta el mes de junio registró un
incremento de 0.1 punto porcentual hasta
ubicarse en 38 por ciento todavía acerca
de los niveles más bajos desde la década
de 1970 pero una señal de que la demanda
de contratación está comenzando a
desacelerarse la cantidad de vacantes de
empleo cayó en 19 mil 800 vacantes a un
millón 274 mil puestos de empleo es la
primera reducción trimestral de este el
período de junio a agosto del 2020
recordemos que en aquel entonces estaba
afectado por la pandemia pero por otro
lado la mayor preocupación se generó en
cuanto al salario y más allá de el
salario nominal en el salario real el
que se refiere a la cantidad de bienes y
servicios que se pueden comprar con el
salario nominal después de contar la
inflación este una reducción de 25 por
ciento el peor dato desde el año 2001
cuando comenzaron los registros no
obstante la oficina de estadísticas
nacionales mostró que el salario total
promedio entre el que se incluyen las
bonificaciones creció un 5,1 por ciento
entre abril y junio del presente año
pasamos al caribe elvis porque el
gobierno cubano anunció que permitirá la
inversión extranjera en el comercio
mayorista y minorista y este se hará a
través de empresas mixtas que el capital
extranjero podrá participar dentro de la
economía cubana el anuncio forma parte
de un paquete de medidas de flexibilidad
flexibilización para dinamizar la
actividad económica que sufre una crisis
desde hace dos años el anuncio fue
realizado por la viceministra de
comercio exterior e inversión extranjera
ana teresita gonzález quien asegura que
las medidas son arriesgadas pero que no
resuelven por sí solas los problemas del
país el objetivo de estas reformas es
lograr una mayor eficiencia en el
comercio minorista nacional los
inversionistas extranjeros podrán crear
entidades para comercial en el mercado
mayorista y conformar empresas mixtas de
manera selectiva para realizar
actividades de comercio minorista estas
nuevas empresas se centrarán en la venta
de materias primas insumos equipamiento
y otros bienes para impulsar el
desarrollo de la producción nacional en
cuba' de inversión extranjera se había
limitado a la producción y el comercio
estaba restringido entidades de carácter
estatal en la nación seguimos de nuestra
américa latina porque en argentina se
conocieron detalles delante del adelanto
extra de ganancias así de raúl se define
como un impuesto que ciertas empresas de
hecho la administración federal estima
que esté por debajo del 1 por ciento de
la cantidad de empresas del país que
estarán pagando por la obtención de
ganancias extraordinarias en periodos
determinados la administración federal
de ingresos públicos ofreció detalles de
este impuesto en el boletín oficial
publicado este martes en el mismo
justifica la medida por la situación
económica que se generó en el mundo como
consecuencia de la guerra entre rusia y
ucrania y que en el caso particular de
argentina como país exportador generó
ganancias extraordinaria a las empresas
de acuerdo con medios argentinos como la
nación el gobierno estima una
recaudación de poco más de 1500 millones
de dólares pero quienes pagarán este
impuesto pues hay dos categorías hay
empresas cuyo impuesto a pagar está por
encima de los 300 millones de pesos
argentinos y éstas deberán adelantar el
25 por ciento de sus ganancias al tiempo
que la que las empresas que ostentan un
impuesto determinado mayor a 100
millones de pesos deberán adelantar un
15 por ciento la iniciativa que por el
momento se pagará una sola vez busca
ayudar a la debilitada economía del país
nos pasamos a eeuu porque en esa nación
hacia adelante una ley que podría louis
frenar una práctica muy común de las
empresas estamos hablando en este caso
de la recompra de acciones la cual
podría pagar un impuesto de acuerdo con
la legislación aprobada que aborda el
cambio climático y que el presidente yo
bailé en prevé promulgar este martes
según el proyecto de ley las empresas
enfrentarán un nuevo impuesto especial
del 1 por ciento sobre las compras de
sus propias acciones pagando una multa
por una y obras que han utilizado
durante mucho tiempo para devolver
efectivo a los inversores y reforzar su
precio en el mercado del impuesto
entrará en vigor en el año 2023 y se
presente en un momento en el que la
recompra de acciones se ha disparado en
la nación para tener una idea las
mayores compañías de eeuu integradas en
el índice standard poor's 500
recompraron títulos propios durante el
tercer trimestre del año 2021 por un
valor de 232 mil millones de dólares
bueno nos vamos de europa vamos a
específicamente hasta alemania porque
ese país avanza en un plan para mitigar
mil defectos de cambiar su principal
proveedor de gas natural hay que
recordar que esta nación hasta el año
pasado ha importado un 55 por ciento del
gas del gas que consume este rusia pero
desde que inició la invasión rusa y
ucrania que ha derivado en otros
problemas entre ellos la interrupción
del suministro de través del gasoducto
nord stream 1
el país adelantado un plan para
encontrar nuevos proveedores alemania
firmó un memorando entendimiento con los
principales importadores de gas para
salvaguardar el suministro en dos
terminales flotantes de gas natural
licuado que necesita para reducir la
dependencia de energía rusa de acuerdo
con la agencia de noticias reuters las
unidades flotantes de almacenamiento y
regasificación
estarán completamente abastecidas para
el comienzo de operaciones en el próximo
invierno y estarán operativas hasta
marzo de 2024 alemania si bien no lo ha
manifestado de una manera directa ha
mostrado preocupación por el impacto que
podría tener una reducción del flujo de
gas en su economía en tal sentido el
canciller o la acción informó desde
estocolmo que los estados miembros de la
unión europea muestran solidaridad si
hay escasez de suministro de energía
debido a la guerra en ucrania
este gravamen es la forma más justa
posible de distribuir y soportar los
costos adicionales que se han acumulado
entre la población la alternativa no es
la falta de gravamen la alternativa
habría sido el colapso del mercado
energético alemán y con él gran parte
del mercado energético europeo banca ni
mixta mente el carnet housing louis y
finalizamos con la cifra del día en el
marco de la conmemoración de la muerte
del display click queremos hablarle de
las más de mil millones de
reproducciones que cuentan las canciones
de la del cantante en la plataforma
spotify hay que señalar que algunas de
estas canciones las más escuchadas han
tenido
569 millones de reproducciones y hay
otras como the house rock que tiene 327
196.300 31 millones de reproducciones
bueno diferentes gracias como siempre
por toda la información económica lo
despido para darle paso fluvial es que
tiene toda la agenda deportiva esta
mañana